foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
functional consequences of the human
enteric viralm in IBD this webinar is
part of the 2022 microbiology virtual
week and I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots so let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during your presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click submit now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that help
desk button located at the bottom of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby finally as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on that continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
Kate Jeffrey the executive director of
modern Therapeutics for a full biography
of our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the left of your screen
Dr Jeffrey welcome you may now begin
your presentation
hi everybody
um it's a pleasure to introduce to you
today our work on um the intestinal
viral where we ask questions about what
viruses in the gut do both in health uh
as well as in inflammatory bowel disease
so you know viruses have all been on
front and center of our minds in the
last couple of years one virus in
particular but it's worth reminding this
audience that you know viruses are
really the most abundant biological
entity on Earth there is estimated to be
10 to the 31 viruses that's a lot of
zeros and to put that into perspective
that's estimated to be more than the
number of stars in the sky or grains of
sand on earth so there are a lot of
viruses I think our challenge in this
space is really annotating a lot of
these viruses there's very few viruses
actually annotated if you look in the
NIH virus database I think it's of the
order of over five thousand so we really
are lagging behind in the identity of
many of these viruses
um but yeah I have questions sort of
arose by really being intrigued by the
fact that us humans Harbor uh many many
viruses uh when we're asymptomatic
um and sort of akin to the microbiome we
sort of asked whether these viruses that
happily exist amongst us with seemingly
causing no pathology we wanted to know
whether they educate our immune system
in sort of beneficial or maladaptive
ways
so it's fair to say within commensal
microorganisms the last 20 years of
research has focused almost exclusively
on the immunomodulatory capacity of
bacteria that inhabit the intestine
um but it is worth noting that all of us
in this audience probably Harbor
anywhere from a million to 100 million
viral-like particles per milligram of
our feces or intestinal tissue so we're
harboring plenty of viruses
um many of those are obviously
prokaryotic viruses that inhabit the
bacteria but some of those are actually
eukaryotic viruses that inhabit our
human cells uh seemingly without causing
any damage and many of those therefore
challenge conscious postulates so they
are not only found in people with
disease they do not transfer disease
some of these viruses uh just in more
than 90 of the human population so if
you take a virus such as a nellovirus
which is a single stranded DNA virus
many of us Harbor this without
um uh much manifest manifestations of
this particular virus
um but the presence of these viruses in
the gut
um it's becoming clear that they
actually do have a protective function
so in mice at least if you eliminate the
viruses in in the gut of a specific
pathogen-free males
or you actually knock out known virus
receptors that would sense those viruses
such as the toylight receptors or
cytosolic sensors such as mda5 or rig
eye those mice actually have exacerbated
intestinal inflammation so getting rid
of those viruses or the ability to sense
those viruses is actually damaging to
the gut
and just as a human genetic connection
it was intriguing to me that uh out of
all the giwa studies that came out of
inflammatory bowel disease uh one
particular loss of function variant that
associated with IBD was actually the
virus sensor mda5 suggesting that a full
functional mda5 is actually important
for protection in the gut
and now we can sequence viruses very
easily using metagenomics
and that has led to a slew of papers
showing that the so-called virome the
prokaryotic and eukaryotic viruses in
our human tissues are altered in a
number of human diseases and I've listed
some here but particularly in Crohn's
and ulcerative colitis patients
but it was fair to say at that point you
know this metagenomic studies were
vastly outpacing our understanding of
um really whether those changes in
viruses contribute to disease
um or really what is their
immunomodulatory capacity uh in both
healthy and diseased States
um and so we sort of think about how
viruses are sensed and usually this is
in the context of an acute pathogenic
infection so many of us know that
viruses are sensed by our innate immune
system either by cytosolic receptors
region mda5 or in designable receptors
toilet receptors as well as many other
helicases and really the goal of this is
to lead a signal transduction program
that leads to the production of type 1
interferon and hundreds of interferon
stimulatory genes whose role it is is
either really to kill that cell or the
virus directly and so we asked well if
this is a real antiviral defense
mechanism do those viruses that
constantly exist in our tissues such as
the gut do they trigger a similar or
different pathway
um and along those lines
um many of the viruses in our gut are
prokaryotic viruses that inhabit the
actual bacteria
um but there's more and more evidence
emerging that actually those prokaryotic
viruses can also have a trans Kingdom
crossover and actually enter into our
human cells either by just simple uptake
by phagocytosis or uptake of the
bacteria and then the viral genome is
there either way there's evidence that
these viruses can actually be sensed by
our host innate immune system as well
and so you know we sort of pose this
very fundamental question of you know is
our immune system clever enough to
distinguish between a virus that is
going to hurt us or one that we've never
seen before versus those that are
happily existing amongst us and so we
asked you know well really in a sort of
equilibrium when the viral
um that we are born with and sort of
continuing to obtain over life do we end
up with a immunological equivalent
equilibrium
or and then what happens in disease do
you get this uh change environment that
leads to A disruption in that
immunological disequilibrium or you um
actually get a very specific response to
certain viruses that are contributing to
disease and so this was sort of a
fundamental innate immune question that
we uh embarked on with this project
so in order to do this we struck up a
fantastic collaboration with Rich hoden
at Mass General Hospital who's a
colorectal surgeon who unfortunately
cuts out many many colons from Crohn's
disease and ulcerative colitis patients
three quarters of Crohn's Disease
patients actually undergo surgery to
remove that inflamed intestine and so we
obtained either fresh colon resections
from Rich straight out of surgery or
actually obtained the fluid from the
ilium of patients that had an earlier an
ilium bag and so the reason we wanted to
focus at these sites I think was really
twofold we wanted to look really at the
site of inflammation and look at the
viruses there but also given that
viruses are obligate pathogens and
really do need host cells to replicate
we wondered whether there were different
viruses actually in the intestinal
tissue then one can detect in the feces
and so um in order to isolate these
viruses or enriched for these viruses we
did a process of size filtration
um now this is by no means a perfect
system this is an enrichment for
viral-like particles using a size
um selection and then we did a
chloroform lysophone lysozyme and dnase
treatment to really get rid of any
bacteria
any host DNA and and ended up with a
fairly pure population of viral-like
particles from these Surgical resections
and so we could do electron microscopy
with these and and clearly see that they
had morphology resembling
um both uh phage as well as eukaryotic
viruses
um and we could quantify these viruses
by using cyber that would stay in DNA
and RNA and we also included dye for a
phospholipid bilayer stain
and importantly for our immune
experiments we wanted to ensure that
these viral-like particle preparations
were endotoxin-free so we did an
additional
step and that was treat them with
polymix and B to get rid of any
endotoxin
so the first thing we did was uh
um have a fantastic collaboration with
Scott Handley uh at um Washington
University in St Louis so I would argue
Scott is really leading the way in
computational analysis uh of the Viro
and so uh with Scott's
um help we sequence both the DNA and RNA
from these viral-like particle
preparations taken from non-ibd patient
controls
ulcerative colitis patients or Crohn's
disease patients
and what's got um's team found was in
fact as published in Theses many of the
viruses in the gut were prokaryotic
viruses
bacteriophage that were both
double-stranded DNA majority
double-stranded DNA or single-stranded
DNA but also in the tissue we were able
to detect a number of eukaryotic viruses
from the families listed here and I just
want to draw your attention to this uh
poconavirus family that we could readily
detect in the intestinal tissue
and so once we started honing in on this
piconavirus family so this is a single
stranded RNA virus family
um what was immediately obvious was
actually all patients with IBD either
ulcerative colitis or Crohn's disease
had a significant elevation uh in
enterovirus B viruses
um now this was missed in previous fecal
metagenomic studies and so really sort
of emphasized how the virum can be
different depending on which area of the
intestine you look at
um and so here we we mapped our reads
back to
annotated viruses and we could see that
the vast majority of these Reeds were
coming from the echo virus 5 family 100
Identity or this b75 family or a lower
identity to this e26 introvirus B family
so as a reminder to you um her Corner
viruses
um are these single stranded RNA
positive sense virus and they're about 7
500 base pairs in length
um and generally has thought to be
sensed by mdo5 in in some preferential
manner
um although you know can be sensed by
other sensors the family
um of coronavirus is then split up into
various genus and then those species
that we've found were enterovirus B and
actually uh we we did not see the
coxsackies and the reason I bring that
up is that coxsackies have already been
associated with type 1 diabetes and have
a particular pancreatic tropism what we
saw was actually
um the echo viruses uh and enteroviruses
uh that have tropism to the gut
um and so uh we are very intrigued by
this and so is this the question of
whether this particular virus is a
environmental Trigger or a contributing
factor to the disease phenotype of IBD
um and that's work undergoing
um in addition to this eukaryotic virus
as published we saw it also changes in a
number of prokaryotic viruses
bacteriophage particularly in Crohn's
disease actually over ulcerative colitis
and these are listed here
um and interestingly when we compared
the virum in the actual colon tissue to
what we found in the ileostomy fluid it
was clear that the richness of the virum
was much higher in the actual tissue now
this is probably a combination of
reasons this is that viruses require
host cells for their replication so
there's probably more viruses in the
actual tissue but also it's known that
phage sit along the sort of mucosal
layer of the intestine and so we're
probably isolating
um those as well but you can clearly see
that in the actual
ileostomy fluid which is even further up
the GI tract than feces obviously the
richness was reduced but nonetheless we
still did see
disease-associated changes Crohn's
disease here in red and ulcerative
colitis here in yellow some changes uh
in the Viro of the ileostomy fluid in
these IBD individuals
and so as Scott's team did a similar
analysis on the ileostomy fluid virome
and here we did not detect the
pecanoviruses but rather this was uh
predominantly uh this single stranded
DNA and nellovirus and there was some
inkling that maybe some of these
actually are reduced in IBD which is an
interesting idea that some of these
protective viruses actually are reduced
in disease and we saw as well a number
of phage in the ileostomy fluid
one um stage that we actually saw that
was specifically enhanced in patients
without IBD was a phage that is
predicted to occupy acomancia and
acomancia is already known to be a
protective bacteria in the gut so we
found that quite interesting that this
particular one was elevated
um but we also saw some go up in IBD and
those are listed here usually from the
micro very day phage family that were
elevated
so now we've identified these viruses
the challenge is really in this field is
being able to culture individual viruses
to work with and that that applies to
both the prokaryotic viruses and the
eukaryotic viruses many of those that we
can identify by sequencing you can't
actually work with them because many of
them aren't culturable yet
so we took the approach of just wanting
to ask or what is the overall immune
response to the collective viruses that
we isolated uh in these human colon
resections so to do this we took primary
human macrophages from healthy donors
just healthy blood donors and then we
put either the non-ibd viruses the
ulcerative colitis viruses or the
collective Crohn's disease viruses on
these primary human macrophages
and the first thing we could see was
that these viruses were certainly taken
up into these macrophages quite readily
so if we label these viruses
um with cyto 16 we could clearly see
that they were taken up and this was
dependent on phagocytosis because if we
did a Golgi block such as profeldene we
didn't see this uptake
um and so the first thing to note is
that um the uptake between the non-obd
UC and CD were equal so anything I'm
about to show you was not because one
had more uptake than the other
um and so if we took the macrophages
after delivering these viral-like
particles from the intestinal resections
to them and then we performed
some sequencing and so the rna-seq
really was uh quite an initial profound
result so that is
um looking at the MDS plot of the
transcriptional program that was induced
in macrophages for non-ibd individuals
so these are five individual patients
really the transcriptional program
induced by those viruses was quite
consistent but was markedly Divergent
from that uh transcriptional program
that was induced by either ulcerative
colitis or Crohn's disease viruses that
actually very well you know they
overlapped quite well in the
transcriptional response
um that they uh they initiated
um it's also worth noting that these
non-ibd viruses from a healthy
uninflamed gut actually were not silent
they actually did induce something uh
different to a mock control so
um but it was just very Divergent from
the IBD viruses
and if we looked at that in another way
we could see that the healthy virum
upregulated a number of genes that very
few of those overlapped which what was
upregulated with the IBD virum
um what was interesting is that the
healthy virus seemed to have this down
regulation of the transcriptional
responsive macrophages uh suggesting
that it was kind of dampening
um the host immune response and this had
again had very little overlap with the
ulcerative colitis or Crohn's disease
firearms that really did overlap quite
tightly in the transcriptional programs
that they induced
but what were the genes induced in
macrophages by these respective virants
as you can see that the health
environment very much dampened the
interferon response so these viruses
collectively down regulated a number of
interferon stimulatory genes a number of
toll like receptors a number of efforts
Etc were all significantly down
regulated in macrophages by these
viruses and what they did up regulate
was actually a very atypical program so
this was certainly not a type 1
interferon program with more a sort of
pro-survival
resolving macrophage type program so
things like cesh isle-4 receptor
um Pro survival factors such as bcl2 uh
the wind pathway Etc
um and this was in
um analyzed by Gene said enrichment
analysis where you could really see this
down regulation of all these interferon
Pathways and actually enough regulation
of these pro-survival pathways
in contrast the ulcerative colitis
viruses on macrophages very much
provoked inflammation so all the classic
cytokines and chemokines that one would
expect from a an innate immune response
things such as il-6 il8 interferon gamma
even il1 Alpha
um R1 beta chemokines Etc and these were
all fit into these pro-inflammatory
pathways
and Crohn's disease Firearms were very
similar so these Collective viruses
again triggered this very much this
pro-inflammatory pathway in macrophages
so I think this was the first evidence
that taking the viruses from IBD
patients where we know that virum is
altered you put it on an innate immune
cell and those viruses very much provoke
inflammation so it suggests that these
viruses are certainly contributing to
the inflammatory environment of
inflammatory bowel disease
if we started taking
um The View that they may polarize
macrophages in different ways we started
to look at Classic so-called M1 M2 genes
and you can see here in blue
um the healthy viruses
um very much
um uh down regulated sort of the M1
genes and upregulated these M2
polarizing genes
um whereas the ulcerative colitis and
Crohn's disease arms pretty much provoke
to sort of M1 pro-inflammatory
polarization
and we confirmed many of the many of
these with many many more viruses from
many more patients I think we got up to
14 patients per group these were all
colon resections taken fresh the virus
is isolated from put on macrophages and
cytokines measured and what was actually
amazing was that the reproducibility of
the virome from individuals so you can
see here the amount of this
anti-inflammatory cytokine into Luke and
10 was quite consistently up regulated
by non-ibd virants
um the pro uh Pro
um or pardon the anti-inflammatory uh
interleukin-22 again very much
upregulated by non-ibd virums as well as
this pro-survival Gene sich
um and importantly to us we wanted to
know whether this was direct sensing of
the nucleic acid of these these viruses
we isolated and so we took the the vlps
we isolated RNA or DNA and we
transfected that into the macrophages at
equal concentration and even when we put
equal concentration of the RNA or DNA
you could very much see that the healthy
virus triggered this anti-inflammatory
interleukin
in stark contrast the IBD virus very
much provoked inflammation very
reproducibly up regulating tnf il-6 as
well as more interferon beta and
importantly to us from innate Immunology
perspective we wanted to really ensure
that none of this had to do with any
contaminating endotoxin and so we've
repeated the same experiments in tall
light receptor for Knockouts so we took
bone marrow derived macrophages from
tall light receptor for Knockouts and we
could see that the amount of
interleukin-6 triggered by Crohn's
disease or ulcerative colitis Firearms
was equal in the absence of tolarg
receptor 4 suggesting that this was
completely independent of this pathway
um and then similarly we isolated RNA
and DNA and transfected that in as equal
amounts and we could see that the IBD
virus very much provoked tnf production
even when transfected in at equal
amounts
so if you think about the innate immune
system what is sensing healthy and IBD
enteric biomes well we know quite a bit
about how the immune system sees viruses
either
um just double-stranded or long
double-stranded RNA in the case of mda5
single stranded RNA perhaps through nod
two we know for rig eye it's definitely
this triphosphate
um sort of Panhandle RNA that this
particular viral sensor recognizes and
of course for DNA either through sea gas
tlr9
Etc and so we just wanted to know what
was the viral moieties that were
detected by the host immune system
um and the first thing was that we knew
that these responses we saw in
macrophages were dependent on a native
in sensing because if we took knockout
cells for mabs which is the downstream
adapter for mda5 or rig eye we had a
reduced response if we knocked out sea
gas we saw a reduced response if we
knocked out Mighty 88 Downstream of
Toler receptors we lost the response but
again this response was intact until
like receptor 4 deficient cells and so
all of these this immunomodulation we're
seeing is dependent on innate immune
sensing either by cytosolic or endosomal
toilet receptors
um if we treated the RNA from these
viruses with rnas or calf intestinal
phosphatase to get rid of phosphate
groups we lost that response so we for
sure it's sort of
um known RNA DNA moieties that are being
sensed by the innate immune system of
these viromes and again we knew sea gas
was involved if you transfect DNA in
because we lost that response in the
absence of seagulls
and so this was an interesting
observation for us that the first time
that the virum from a healthy gut was
actually protective could trigger this
anti-inflammatory pathway whereas the
IBD virum very much provoked
inflammation so we sort of asked the
question well if that's the case maybe
in a similar way to fecal transfers
of microbiome the virome or the healthy
vironment could be used as a therapy so
could we suppress the inflammatory
response induced by IBD Firearms by
delivering uh healthy virums in
increased concentrations and this is
just in vitro but in human macrophages
in red we could see that the IBD virum
triggered substantial interleukin-6 and
as we increased the amount of healthy
viruses on top of that the healthy
viruses not only on their own could
trigger anti-inflammatory responses but
actually could start to suppress the
inflammatory response induced by IBD
virus and we could see this as well with
tnf
um and we asked whether this was a
direct effect of the viruses or this was
because of anti-inflammatory mediators
that we'd already seen were induced so
we took the supernatant from those
macrophages previously infected with um
healthy virus from patient colon
resections and essentially asked whether
that supernatant could also suppress the
response to an IBD virus and so in light
blue here you could see that definitely
whatever is in that supernatant likely
interleukin 10 interleukin 22 could
readily reduce the inflammatory response
driven by the IBD virum if we heat
inactivated that that would get rid of
soluble proteins we lost that effect but
if we UV inactivate that which would
cross-link viruses we could still see an
effect so it's very much suggesting that
it's anti-inflammatory mediators in that
supername driven by the non-ibd virum
that could be protected so this sort of
suggests to us that much like the
microbiome perhaps virome transfers
could be considered for IBD therapy
where healthy viruses delivered
um could actually be suppressive of
inflammatory responses and it's worth
commenting here that in C difficile
infection this has actually already been
shown where fecal transfers or fecal
contents were filtered out for bacteria
and the filtered
product was delivered and actually that
also showed to have an effect on C
difficile infections so the non-bacteria
component of fecal transfers has already
been shown to be able to immunomodulate
and be protected
so all of what I've shown you is in
cells we did this also in intestinal
epithelial cells to show this diversion
effect but we really wanted to know in
Vivo what these viruses could do so we
humanized mice uh with
um viruses that we'd isolated from
column resections from non-ibd patients
ulcerative colitis or Crohn's disease
patients
and to do that we first treated these
mice with an antiviral cocktail which is
a published cocktail to sort of reduce
the murine virum and that did about a
20-fold reduction or we saw about a
20-fold reduction in the viruses present
in an SPF black six Mouse
um and then we delivered by gavage these
human viruses that we'd isolated from
these columnar sections and we gave that
by three gavages
um and we could quantify that here
either in the colon tissue itself or in
the feces the antiviral cocktail got rid
of viruses and we got actually a quite a
decent amount of viruses in the feces as
well as the colon tissue uh following
this kavage
so the first thing we asked was was
there any um spontaneous ability of
these viruses to uh affect the host
immune system and so we took lamina
propria immune cells after the garage
and just looked whether these viruses
were capable of changing immune cell
populations in the lemon appropriate of
these months and so uh if we looked at
uh cx3 cr1 positive
mononuclear phagocytes in the gut which
are a known pro-inflammatory
um phagocyte in the gut we very much saw
that
um
the IBD virum expanded this population
spontaneously when we delivered these
either ulcerative colitis or Crohn's
disease Firearms to these mice
and we could quantitate that both by
percentage as well as total counts we
saw this significant expansion of cx3
cr1 uh positive mononuclear phagocytes
by delivering IBD virum to these uh
normally healthy Minds
in contrast what we saw was actually the
non-ibd virum in blue could actually
um enhance the numbers and percentages
of these cd-103 positive mononuclear
phagocytes which have been shown to
actually be able to promote T regulatory
cell expansion in the gut so on the one
hand the IBD viruses spontaneously
expanded inflammatory monocytes whereas
the healthy Viro led to an expansion of
these more protective City 103 positive
mononuclear phagocytes
and so then we wanted to induce colitis
in these mice and ask was the healthy
Viro I'm able to protect these Mass from
colitis and in contrast was the
ulcerative colitis virome or Crohn's
disease virum capable of exacerbating uh
chemical induced colitis in these months
and so one crude readout for intestinal
inflammation is just simply measuring
colon length so the shorter the colon
the more inflammation and so in Gray was
the mice that had been treated with that
antiviral cocktail and we sequenced
those mice and we definitely saw that
there were alterations in both the virum
and the microbiome in those mice but as
published that antiviral cocktail really
does exacerbate intestinal inflammation
so
taking away viruses from us has
repercussions for intestinal health
what we did see though was the ability
to rescue that quite beautifully by
gavaging in those healthy viruses though
rather the virus is taken from a healthy
intestine
um we could see that they very much
protected these Mice from induced DSS
colitis whereas the IBD viruses could
not do that
another readout of intestinal
inflammation is looking at lipocalon in
the stool which is usually a marker of
neutrophil infiltration
again taking away viruses with the
antiviral cocktail increased still like
the calendar significantly and we could
rescue that quite beautifully by
gavaging those healthy viruses into that
mice whereas the IBD viruses could not
rescue the stool-like account
similarly if you measured the
pro-inflammatory cytokine interleukin-6
in the actual colon tissue we could see
that the taking away the viruses
increase interleukin-6 putting healthy
virus back into these mice rescued that
and that could not be rescued by the IBD
viruses
uh and a number of other readouts we
looked at histology which was blindly
scored by a pathologist very much
reduced inflammation here in blue in the
healthy viral humanized mice whereas the
IBD viruses viral mice very much had
inflammation
uh interestingly too in addition to just
inflammatory cytokine production in the
gut and infiltration of leukocytes we
looked at intestinal leakiness of these
mice so you can Garage in fixies dextran
and if the gut is leaky you can then
measure that in the blood
um and actually in yellow and red here
the IBD virum very much provoked
um sort of intestinal leakiness which is
as another
um sort of indicator of inflammatory
bowel disease
so collectively in Vivo these human
Firearms
um contributed to disease state so on
the one hand the healthy Viro protected
the gut in Vivo and on the other hand
either ulcerative colitis or Crohn's
disease virus very much provoked
inflammation in Vivo so suggesting that
the changes with metagenomic studies
seen in IBD these viruses are actually
contributing to disease phenotype
so the next question we asked was was
any of this dependent on host sensing of
the nucleic acids of these viruses so in
other words in Vivo of course we can't
exclude the contribution of the
microbiome by delivering these viruses
to the to these masks and we did
certainly look at 16s
um sequencing we did see some changes in
the microbiome but actually only really
for the Crohn's disease delivered
viruses
so we went back to our mice and we
wanted to ask specifically with all of
the work we've done in human macrophages
showing the Divergent innate immune
response to these viruses was this
relevant to the different disease
phenotypes that we'd seen in fever
and so we took either mads Knockouts
that cannot signal Downstream of regular
mda5 viral sensors
um or sea gas Knockouts which cannot
sense DNA and in both cases mabs
Knockouts or sea gas Knockouts we really
lost any immunomodulation of these human
viruses that we were delivering
um via guavas to these mice so we didn't
see really any effect of these human
biomes that we had delivered to the mice
in the absence of either RNA sensing or
DNA sensing
so this is really strong evidence that
the innate immune system is
um really the key sensor of these
viruses both in health and disease so on
the one hand for any benefit of the
healthy virum you need sensing by the
innate immune system or any inflammation
triggered by the IBD virum you need
sensing by the hostinate immune system
so that was all in mice and we'd done
human macrophages in vitro and we've
done uh look at humanized mice in Vivo
to look at disease phenotype
um and I sort of wanted to get back to
this genetic Association of the viral
sensor mda5 with inflammatory bowel
disease so many of you on this call and
and many of you in this field know that
mda5 is a cytosolic sensor of long
double-stranded RNA
and in many autoimmune diseases actually
um so-called interferonopathies you see
a gain of function actually of mda5 that
contributes to these diseases
and in IBD actually what we see is the
opposite it is a loss of function
variant of mda5 that uniquely Associates
with inflammatory bowel disease so this
suggested to us that this you know shows
us that mda5 in the gut at least is
really needed
for maintaining intestinal Health in
response to the viral and so in pink
here are the the main mutations that
associate with inflammatory bowel
disease so it was either this isoleucine
923s in the c-terminal domain is mutated
to a veiling or you have a splice
variant in the c-terminal domain or you
have this truncated mutant which
essentially truncates here so all of
these end up with a lack of function C
terminal domain and we wanted to confirm
that these are truly loss of function
and so we just Express these mutants in
HEX cells and found that indeed these
are loss of function mutations
and so just to take you through this
either expressing wild type mda5 to no
RNA or sulf RNA where we'd isolated RNA
from the cytosol of the same cells
triggered
um or did it on its own without RNA
triggered and interferon response but in
the presence of a known in da5 ligand
polyic that interferon response was
exacerbated and we also isolated our
human vlps from colon resections and
showed that in the same luciferous assay
they could trigger an interferon
response that was mda5 dependent but the
mutants either the truncated version or
the I-93 V mutation
all inhibited the ability of these
healthy viruses or polyic to induce
a sort of a downstream response of mda5
and so with John Ryu up at Montreal we
then took a step further where we
isolated
um uh ipscs from patients that were
carrying these mda5 loss of function
mutations and John's group has a
beautiful system where they can take
those ipscs and convert them to
essentially spheroids or organoids and
then we can create either these organoid
cultures or these 2D cultures and we did
this in it with intestinal epithelial
cells because mda5 actually is
predominantly expressed in the
intestinal epithelium
um and so what we saw was a an all sort
of colitis patient that had this um
compound was a compound heterozygote
actually for both of these mutations uh
in a loss of function of mda5 and we
could see that um under normal
circumstances that intestinal epithelium
looked fairly normal
um look with e coherin or z01 or f-actin
that mutation really didn't change the
intestinal epithelium in any obvious way
but in a 2d culture when we started
delivering either healthy Viro or IBD
Viro we could start to see this very
significant loss of epithelial Integrity
barrier uh in the ABS in the sort of
presence of this mda5 loss of function
mutation so without mda5 functionality
the virum was much more damaging and
even if you put an IBD virum on top of
that you get that added additive effect
where you're still have got a genetic
susceptibility Gene plus an IBD virum
results in a lack of intestinal barrier
integrity
and we looked at the ability of these
intestinal epithelial cells to produce
the predictive cytokine interferon
Lambda and we could see that the healthy
Viro triggered interferon Lambda
production and this was lost in that
patient that was carrying this compound
heterozygote mutation Within mda5
so this is some human evidence that mda5
is necessary for sensing of the Viro and
actually loss of function variance in
IBD patients actually lose any
beneficial effect of the Viro but also
when you have an altered firearm on top
of that it leads to even more
exacerbated inflammation
so in summary
um I think we've done a really large
foray into trying to understand the
human intestinal viral I think up to
this point you know really the virum was
lagging very behind the microbiome
largely because of the techniques in
which we detect it and so once
sequencing became cheap and easy and
ways to computationally align viruses
much much data has come out of
associating viruses or changes in the
virum with disease but we were still
really left with correlative data the
question we talked or asked was what
does the virum do to the innate immune
system in health and what does it do in
the context of inflammatory bowel
disease
so I think our data has really clearly
shown in both the reductionist system
where we just put the viruses we
isolated from the intestinal colon on
human macrophages in a dish the healthy
viruses very much provoked an
anti-inflammatory pathway which was an
atypical viral response so it wasn't a
type 1 interferon-induced response
actually that if anything that was down
regulated and instead what was up
regulated was this pro-survival
um
anti-inflammatory pathway and in stark
contrast the IBD viruses are very much
provoked inflammation so I think we can
confidently say
um from the human macrophage experiments
that a reductionist system viruses on
their own can actually
trigger inflammation so the IBD virus
trigger inflammation and then even in
Vivo when we humanize those mice very
much the healthy virome was protective
whereas the IBD virum provoked
inflammation and actually even
spontaneously provoked that expansion of
those cx3 cr1 positive mononuclear
phagocytes
so I think uh we're at a juncture here
in Byron research I think we've now
shown that the immune system certainly
doesn't ignore these viruses in health
and these viruses that are altered can
contribute to disease phenotype
um the questions you know we have moving
forward is really
um is it that it's the change in the
virum specifically is its certain
appearance of viruses such as the
introvirus B family that's really
triggering this inflammation that's a
very very likely hypothesis or outcome
but the same
um or sort of a separate hypothesis is
really that whether the same viruses
could be doing different things
depending on the immune State and we've
seen this for certain bacteria where a
so-called symbiont can become a
pathobion in the context of inflammation
and so we're very interested in this Con
in this concept of whether the IBD virum
triggers inflammation because of the
appearance of enteroviruses and other
phage that aren't normally seen in
healthy state but at the same breath do
some normally healthy viruses such as
Anella viruses say actually start being
pro-inflammatory in a prime inflammatory
environment and these are the types of
questions that we'll be asking moving
forward
I think what was really convincing for
me was this a genetic Association of the
virus receptor mda5 with IBD so we
showed quite clearly that that is a loss
of function mutation in mda5 that
Associates with IBD if we took um
intestinal epithelial cells from a
patient that it was a compound
heterozygote for that loss of function
clearly there was detrimental
consequences for that so you really do
need a functional mda5 receptor
sensing the healthy virum and really
when you lose that you can actually
there's detrimental consequences for the
intestinal epithelial cells
so I think collectively our work really
does show that the virum is not ignored
the healthy virus certainly is not
ignored and in a similar way to the
microbiome actually works to educate our
immune system and and keep sort of our
intestine
um in a healthy state by provoking sort
of these anti-inflammatory pro-survival
Pathways and it can do that autonomous
autonomously to the microbiome
um and in contrast the IBD virum very
much provokes inflammation
and so the idea here is you know well
can we take this a step forward on the
one hand can we start to harness the
healthy virum in a similar way to the
microbiome to sort of suppress
inflammation in IBD
but then on the flip side what can we do
about the IBD viruses and so can we
start to try and eliminate some of these
viruses in IBD that we think are
contributing to this inflammatory uh
phenotype and I think this will be the
really the the next Frontier in
environment research
um and so with that obviously I get to
tell all of you about the work we've
done
um this is the been the hard work of of
many people in my lab but particularly
uh Fatima adiliagdam who was just a
stellar postdoc who really LED this
project Fatima is now training to be a
surgeon herself so after all this work
looking at colon resection she's now
actually getting to do some surgery
herself so I look forward to having her
as a physician
um surgery scientist colleague in the
future I want to point out hajira
amatula another postdoc in the lab as
well as Isabella and really everyone in
the Jeffrey lab that helped us with this
project this was a new frontier for my
lab so really collaborations were key I
want to point out particularly Scott
Hanley who really again I just want to
emphasize is really leading the field in
firearm computational analysis and we
couldn't have identified all those
viruses in those surgery resections
without him
um I also want to give a shout out to
Romney Xavier and Richard Xavier at MGH
has set up an enormous
um uh registry of IBD patients at Mass
General Hospital so it allows us
researchers access to tissues blood
um whatever we like biopsies uh from
these um uh genotyped individuals which
has been just such a fantastic resource
to try and understand inflammatory bowel
disease and of course computational help
and as well as John ryu's team in
Montreal who made the intestinal
epithelial organoids from us from these
mda5 loss of function patients
um so I'm obviously not there live thank
you everyone for your attention what I
will say is that I'm very happy to be
answering questions via email so if you
have questions about this work and the
field more generally please reach out
and I'll respond as soon as I can and
thank you uh for your attention
I want to thank you Dr Jeffrey for your
time today and for your important
research and before we go I want to
thank our audience for joining us today
as well questions submitted today and
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
September 7th
2024. lab rates will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye